las vegas raiders putting the spotlight
on high school football once again this
time at arbor view high school eight
sports kevin martin they're ahead of the
raiders friday night showcase game
yeah thanks guys we're here at the
raiders friday night showcase game
overview hosting centennial and a huge
friday night showdown and i'm joined by
former raider leo gray let's reminisce a
little bit leo what was it like for you
i mean essentially there's nothing quite
like friday night lights
um very exciting you know you got a lot
of people watching you know friday most
people are off work so they get a chance
to come out after work and see some kids
bang it up a little bit and when it's a
rivalry it makes it all that much more
better so i still remember the games
going back you know when we played a
rival and how exciting it was and you
know how much fun and just you know the
whole atmosphere about being out there
being able to play so it's a good thing
you know as long as we continue to do it
and the support that the raiders give
you know is big time before i let you go
has it ever been this hot for a friday
night lights game for you back in high
school do you ever ever remember being
in triple digits well i'm from
california so it was never like this
up underneath this thing thank goodness
it's black you know i'm dripping down
i'm sweating i need to burn some
calories anyway thank you so much leo
have fun tonight and of course we'll
have highlights of our view and
centennial coming up at 11. reporting
live at arbor view high school kevin
martin 8 sports now